vor kurzem hat uns unsere zuschauerin
kerl ein well gefragt ob wir ein video
über werben mit fair machen können und
hier sind wir bei minus zehn grad in
berlin und los geht's fair ist ein
präfix im deutschen es steht am anfang
von super vielen werben ich glaub
tausenden in deutschen und es sind immer
untrennbare werben jetzt aber die
wichtigste frage für euch gibt es eine
verknüpfung zwischen all den werben mit
ca
gibt es eine bedeutung hat für eine
bedeutung diese frage können wir mit ja
und mit nein beantworten ich weiß das
ist nicht so zufriedenstellend aber die
geschichte ist ein bisschen kompliziert
ich habe auch ein bisschen dazu
recherchiert und eigentlich die beste
erklärung die ich gefunden habe war in
manuels blog german is easy bei your
daily german dot com den link post ich
mal unten und er erzählt ein bisschen
woher dieses verkommt denn fair ist ein
präfix das schon hunderte jahre alt ist
und natürlich verändert sich das über
die zeit
es gibt aber so etwas wie er es gibt
keine übersetzung von fair aber
vielleicht so ein gefühl das man hat
wenn ich werben mit verhöre viele viele
haben so ein gefühl von etwas geht weg
etwas verschwindet etwas ja sage ich mal
diese bewegung habe ich ganz oft bei
sehr im kopf und was das heißt das
zeigen wir euch jetzt an ein paar
beispielen in der ersten gruppe von
verben die wir euch zeigen geht es darum
dass etwas falsch gemacht wird
und hier können wir einige wortpaare
bilden nämlich mit den gleichen werben
einmal ohne und mit fair und dann
versteht ihr vielleicht die bedeutung
dieser ersten gruppe wenn etwas falsch
läuft wenn etwas schief läuft
das erste beispiel ist laufend janus
läuft auf der straße ganz normal ohne
richtung ohne besondere bedeutung
das zweite beispiel ist verlaufen janus
verläuft sich auf der straße heißt dass
er nicht mehr weiß wo er ist oder nicht
mehr weiß wo er hin wollte
er ist in die falsche richtung gegangen
das zweite beispiel ist schreiben
janisch schreibt ganz normal aber
janosch verschreibt sich heißt er hat
etwas falsch geschrieben das dritte
beispiel ist wählen
janisch wählt eine telefonnummer in
seinem handy jetzt hat janis sich
verwählt fair wählen heißt das ja noch
die falsche nummer angerufen hat das
nächste beispiel ist legen
januar schlägt seine kamera auf den
tisch aber was passiert wenn man etwas
verlegt janus hat seine kamera verlegt
das heißt er weiß nicht mehr wo er sie
hingelegt hat die kamera ist weg janosch
schluckt etwas zb schluckt er eine
tablette mit wasser aber wenn man sich
verschluckt dann hat man nicht richtig
geschluckt dann ist zum beispiel wasser
in die luftröhre gekommen
oh nein ihr seht das fair ist immer
etwas mehr was weggeht von einem in der
ersten gruppe sind das sachen die falsch
gelaufen sind oder sogar verloren
gegangen sind
jetzt haben wir noch einige deutlichere
beispiele in der zweiten gruppe gibt es
immer etwas was verschwindet was weggeht
was aufhört oder was stoppt hier haben
wir ein beispiel kaufen wenn ich etwas
kaufe dann kaufe ich es zu mir ich kaufe
eine banane das heißt sie war vorher im
geschäft jetzt gehört sie mir wenn ich
allerdings etwas verkaufe geht es weg
von mir ich verkaufe mein handy es ist
weg dann danach wenn ich wette
dann setze ich geld
auf ein bestimmtes chance dass etwas
passiert wenn ich mich ja wenn ich alles
fair wette ich habe mein ganzes geld
verwettet dann ist es weg alles ist weg
von mir gegangen etwas verschwindet
janisch kamera ist verschwunden man
findet sie nicht mehr wieder sie ist weg
ich verliere etwas panisch hat seine
kamera verloren
hoffentlich nicht für immer aber dieses
verb verlieren das impliziert die
bedeutung dass es weg ist für immer ich
habe etwas verloren verpassen
ich habe das konzert verpasst ich war
zum beispiel krank ich konnte nicht zum
konzert gehen
das konzert ist jetzt vorbei ich kann
nie wieder zu diesem konzert gehen ich
habe es verpasst das konzert ist weg
wehr setzen
ich habe mich mit janisch verabredet
aber ich bin nicht gekommen ich habe
auch nicht angerufen
ich habe ihn versetzt also ich habe ihn
alleine stehen gelassen ich bin nicht zu
ihm gekommen
vergessen ich habe etwas vergessen das
heißt etwas ein gedanke war in meinem
kopf ich sollte dann etwas denken
der gedanke ist weg ich habe ihn
verloren ich habe etwas vergessen das
heißt es ist auch weg gegangen ja in
diesen ersten beiden gruppen von
beispielen konntet ihr sehen dass man
die werben mit fair immer mit ja mit
dieser bewegung verknüpfen kann oder mit
dieser idee verknüpfen kann dass etwas
weg geht etwas verschwindet etwas geht
weg von einem mann verliert etwas in
manchen fällen läuft etwas schief etwas
ist falsch nicht immer ist das so
einfach zu erklären es gibt eine ganze
reihe von werben da ist
die erklärung nicht mehr so einfach oder
sie ist vielleicht etwas
man muss das ganze in einem größeren
bild in einem größeren kontext sehen und
das liegt eben daran dass diese silbe
und auch diese werben zum teil schon
sehr alt sind und sich die bedeutungen
auch über viele jahrzehnte und
jahrhunderte verändert haben
ich habe jetzt noch eine dritte gruppe
und in dieser dritten gruppe würde ich
sagen dass das fair so etwas wie eine
langfristige oder nachhaltigere
veränderung ausdrückt ich lese mal
einige beispiele vor vielleicht bekommt
ihr dann so eine verständnis dafür
versuchen zwei verändern to change
verschieben to move oder auch fair
handeln vertrauen und verstehen
auf den ersten blick haben all diese
worte nichts miteinander gemeinsam
aber wenn man das ja vielleicht ein
bisschen dieses gefühl dass dieses faire
mitbringt verstehen möchte kann man sich
vorstellen dass sich etwas verändert
oder etwas ja man etwas grundsätzlich
verändert ich versuche etwas heißt es
gibt einen zustand und den möchte ich
vielleicht verändern indem ich etwas
neues versuchen
ich verändere etwas da ist das im wort
schon drin also ich möchte etwas ändern
ich verschiebe etwas das heißt vorher
war etwas hier zum beispiel einen termin
oder ein schrank und ich schiebe ihn
hier hin
oder ich vertraue jemanden das heißt ich
habe ein gewisses ja ein gewisses gefühl
für jemanden ich vertraue jemanden dass
es auch vielleicht eine veränderung von
einfach jemandem mit jemandem einem
normales gefühl haben zu jemandem
vertrauen das ist auch ein rad wechseln
ich weiß nicht auf diese erklärung
geholfen hat aber ich hoffe ihr habt so
ein bisschen ein bild bekommen was
dieses fair bedeutet ja wir hoffen euch
hat das video geholfen
zumindest ein bisschen zu verstehen was
diese silbe fair im deutschen bedeutet
es gibt natürlich noch viele andere
beispiele da passt diese erklärung oder
diese bedeutung nicht immer 100 prozent
man muss die verben am ende einfach
auswendig lernen so ist es aber jetzt
habt ihr vielleicht so ein bisschen ein
grobes verständnis von fair
ihr könnt natürlich noch übungen machen
jetzt das geht bei petschel ihr könnt
uns auch abonieren darüber freuen uns
sehr und wenn ihr auch mal ein thema
habt was ihr gerne erklärt haben möchtet
was ihr nicht versteht oder ein fehler
den wir immer wieder macht schreibt uns
wir freuen uns immer über eure
vorschläge für neue videos und bis bald